un temible doble récord las autoridades
rusas reportaron el mayor número de
contagios por kobe 19 con un total de 31
mil 299 casos y 986 muertes tan sólo
este jueves la máxima cifra hasta la
fecha unos números que preocupan al
gobierno por lo que el presidente ruso
vladimir putin hizo un llamado a
acelerar la vacunación expuesto y la
vacuna protege a las personas de la
infección con síntomas graves lo sabemos
muy bien y necesitamos aumentar su ritmo
les pido que participen activamente en
esta actividad la baja tasa de
vacunación se explica en parte por la
desconfianza de la población en las
autoridades y el miedo hacia los nuevos
productos así como el surgimiento de la
variante delta a pesar de que el
gobierno ha aprobado el uso de cuatro
vacunas según la universidad johns
hopkins sobre el 31% de la población
tiene una pauta completa de vacunación
hoy tenemos el 42 por ciento de las
personas mayores de 60 años vacunadas
eso no es suficiente la infección por
persona virus también afecta a la
población más joven personas de 20 a 25
años
según la jefe sanitaria rusa 77 de las
85 regiones del país registran un
incremento en la tasa de incidencia del
coronavirus situación que ha llevado a
la ocupación de las camas hospitalarias
destinadas a los pacientes contagiados
por el virus a una ocupación del 90 por
ciento
mientras que los casos aumentan muchos
culpan al gobierno de no haber sabido
manejar la crisis sanitaria